the things you didn't know Series has
finally arrived in tears of the kingdom
and boy have we found some mind-boggling
discoveries already before we jump in
just know that we're keeping this as
spoiler light as possible if you still
enjoy this series hit that like button
because we got a wild ride
in the previous game this bridge in
kakariko Village had a secret Apple
underneath that the developers hit well
in tears of the kingdom it got a new
friend a second Apple if you use a
freezing weapon on any body of water
it'll create handy ice blocks just like
we've shown in a previous tips video
this is a great way to protect your
shield for shield surfing and can be
used to make vehicles and of course by
itself it makes a fan and a freezing
weapon at the same time
another bonus with this is that it can
be shot with shock arrows to conduct
damaging electricity in a wide area of
effect this is funny because apparently
ice is a pretty poor conductor of
electricity Shield surfing can also be
used on Rails and you can transfer rails
by jumping the best way to kick start
your Shield surfing trip though is with
the rocket shield first many players
have found some great ways to make
Shield surfing more fun such as using
mine carts regular carts or the slabs of
ice but carts are fairly rare and Ice
doesn't last very long but what if I
told you there's an infinitely better
option right under your nose frozen meat
freezing a slab of meat will make an
insanely low friction Shield Surf and
even different Meats have different
properties no this isn't serpent Turf
this is surf on Turf
just like in breath of the wild the
Zoras still don't fancy electricity and
will often immediately cower or run in
fear well if you want to make friends
instead a bit of fresh water is a decent
piece offering when up against a battle
Talus you can Ascend up the platforms
and even through the talus itself and an
easy way to knock off its buddies off of
their platforms is to use a muddle Bud
on the talus it will aggro on its own
friends and send them flying off their
perch
when using the zonai small wheels on a
creation there's a secret input you
likely missed by turning in One
Direction then quickly breaking and
turning in the other direction easiest
done with a half moon motion on the
controller you can actually drift your
vehicle in tears of the Kingdom you can
tell you did this correctly by the sound
of Tire squealing
here's a neat way to get bullet time in
combat hold a rock then Ascend as soon
as possible great for dodging attacks
and easy bullet time another secret tip
while building or grabbing certain
materials is simply using the ZL button
to flatten whatever you're holding the
really cool thing about this flattened
ability is that it's buffed with
specific items such as sleds construct
heads and homing cars as it will auto
turn it upright at larger angles
compared to other pieces because for the
most part these pieces want to be
upright anyways diving down a deep hole
can be kind of scary especially since
you can't see the bottom well a super
easy trick is to drop a bright Bloom
seed midair while you're diving now you
can see what your landing area will look
like and how far away it is ruin Rubble
that falls from the sky is not only a
good elevator but also a decent
attachment to fuse to your weapon also
if you tried to reach Zelda study in
Hyrule Castle you may have been greeted
by a nasty surprise the bridge before it
collapses right beneath your feet cool
thing is you can fuse these pieces as
well literally taking pieces of Hyrule
castle with you
Dazzle fruits are an amazing way to
dispatch stall enemies no more
scrambling around during battle one
throw and it's over an interesting way
to detonate items on a small timer is by
setting them on fire things like muddle
buds pushrooms Dazzle fruits and others
can be burned by igniting them and they
will set them off after being burned up
Gloom is some pretty nasty stuff quickly
chipping away at Link's Hearts but he
can actually Shield surf safely over it
without being armed remember to always
bring your best skateboard or surfboard
did you know that if it's raining after
you warp to a shrine and want to use a
campfire to change the weather just use
the entrance of the shrine as a
makeshift roof to light your fire
just like in breath of the wild Sapphire
fused rods are great for farming and
knock a bunch of materials off of trees
and one Fell Swoop a slightly slower but
definitely cooler way is to use Auto
build by having a schematic of a bunch
of apples stuck together you can use the
built-in pull mechanism to pull
materials directly to you a personal
aerial vacuum this makes grabbing
multiple things from up high a breeze
did you know that you can Parry your own
Cannonball
you may have found that fusing mushrooms
to equipment will give them bouncy
properties but there is a secret
technique with this slap even the most
basic Mushroom on the weakest shield and
now it has the ability to 100 guarantee
a disarm against even the most powerful
weapon knocking them clean out of enemy
hands shock emitters are slightly
different from frost and Flame emitters
the emitter itself actually conducts
electricity Dazzle fruits when used to
stun most enemies in the game but don't
affect like likes because well they
don't have eyes
you can make interesting Arrow
interactions by having a source of fire
nearby you can now fuse an arrowhead
then light it on fire to have both at
the same time this can make for some
fire electric hybrid Arrows Long range
updrafts with spicy peppers or sun
shrooms and even a budget fire keysai
arrow did you know that a gliox tail
whip can be flurry rushed
tired of breaking weapons well our good
friend The Rock octorock can now
completely fix up any weapon that's
busted up and even throw a bonus random
modifier on top of it what a good friend
you can also hit an enemy with a thrown
weapon without breaking it by simply
recalling it back to you
Nintendo has already hit the game with a
patch that has fixed a bunch of glitches
a mere two weeks after release things
that are not possible anymore include
multiple duplication glitches a glitch
called zuglink to hold to multiple
weapons at the same time overloading
with that to lose body parts and typos
and clip through the ground to see
underneath Hyrule stealing the master
sword out of the first intro sequence
and playing the game with it putting
modifiers on weapons that are normally
impossible and using Auto build cancel
slide to fly across the map at insanely
high speeds it looks like Nintendo is
not quite as relaxed as they were in the
days of breath of the wild and will
likely see constant updates to fix these
glitches
thank you courser B honey when fused
lets you summon an angry swarm of bees
that attacked the closest thing to them
but this can be multiplied when shot
with multi-shot arrows a cool detail
with bees just like in real life is that
smoke is a great deterrent for bees
which will disperse when touching smoke
link now has a new special passive when
charging up a spin attack with swords
only unlike in breath of the wild he now
actually has increased resistance to
stagger also known as super armor be
careful though because very powerful
attacks will still knock you off your
feet also with Shield fused two-handed
weapons by rolling your fingers from y
to B to a you can cancel your Spin
Attack and Parry directly out of it
making Shield fused spin to wins
extremely safe also as an upgrade from
breath of the wild if you ever
accidentally fall into water with zero
stamina you'll now get emergency last to
stamina to try to get the Solid Ground
some players may have had some
difficulty building their Creations
because depending on the shape of the
creation keeping things upright can be
kind of tough well the perfect tool is
the zonai stake which can be pushed into
the ground to make a garage Jack to hold
your Contraptions up in the air for you
oil and pine cone are a new type of
material that can create a powerful fire
and updraft so you might be thinking
great I'll just set it on fire well hold
on there's a special rule these
materials have a specific order they
need the fire first then the oil fuel
added second to set them off correctly
hot air balloons don't necessarily need
flame emitters any source of fire works
fine and the previously shown fueled
fires give bonus speed to hot air
ballots making them rise faster than
normal on top of that these fueled fires
have a secret ability normal fires are
easily put out by rain but these
powerful fires cannot be doused by rainy
weather
most NPCs when attacked simply put their
arm up or look in shock if you attack
them but some others react differently
such as holding up a newspaper or
protecting himself with a helmet flux
constructs are fearsome enemies you can
meet early in the game but they are
especially weak to two abilities fuse
and Ultra hand you can either steal six
blocks directly off their body with
either ability which then makes them
collapse and fall to the ground or with
ultra hand go directly for the main
block and Shake It Off quickly attaching
random Parts together with ultra hand
will also cause it to fall apart
and as a subtle nod to breath of the
wild with guardians you can stand
directly on top of their head and
they'll be completely confused Lux
constructs also can't attack link
without their corresponding parts and
its humanoid form if you take their
hands they can't slam you
take their feet they can't stop you now
go for a friendly dance-off or play some
rock paper scissors
I guess this is a tie
[Music]
there you go 42 amazing things you could
do in tears of the kingdom and you know
this is only the beginning of a long
journey through discovering tears of the
Kingdom's many Secrets let us know your
favorite facts you learned and of course
for More Tears of the Kingdom content
stay right here on Gamespot
[Music]